i think one of the things if i were to
rewind five years and play things over
again
and it seems very very simple it does
it's very intuitive but i think this one
thing would go a long way for anybody
starting their dream
[Music]
hi everyone i'm bruno aziza and welcome
to another great episode of data
journeys this is the place that we come
to learn from leaders in data and
analytics
leaders who have achieved amazing
results and growth significant outcomes
and are willing to spend some time with
us to share their lessons their do's and
don'ts and their stories and so today i
have the pleasure of talking with mike
mike is vice president of data analytics
at geotab he was a ceo before a company
whose team was acquired by geotab he's
an amazing entrepreneur and has achieved
very amazing things over the last five
years so we want to hear from him mike
thank you so much for taking the time to
talk to us today let's get started what
does geotap do first
yeah no pleasure being here uh bruno so
geotab we're the world's largest
commercial telematics provider what that
means effectively is we work with a lot
of commercial fleet so we've got a
device that plugs into the onboard
diagnostic port of vehicles you know
over two million commercially connected
vehicles and voted number one by abi
research across the the globe and we
provide all of our customers with a
number of insights everything from safe
driving to fleet optimization better
routing and we have this wide network of
partners and we created this platform to
allow our partners to help our customers
to build some amazing products on top of
the ecosystem and then from all of this
data it's my team that really looks at
this data and figures how do we drive
further insight for our customers from
this you know this vast amount of data
that's coming into the ecosystem on on a
daily basis
so 2 million commercial
vehicles that's 40 billion data points a
day we're talking a lot of data a lot of
changing data so take us through the use
cases that are deployed today so i mean
we've got a number of different use
cases we've got about 40 to 50 000
customers that are kicking around out
there and the problem with that is that
you have so many disparate use cases
right i've got customers who are running
fleets of size one to over a hundred
thousand in different verticals some are
municipal vehicles uh some are vehicles
uh that do last mile delivery uh some
are construction vehicles so it's just
such a wide array so
what we've done is we try to look at
what we can create broadly that will
help our ecosystem deliver more impact
and one of the areas that we've done a
lot of work in is predictive maintenance
picture you know a vehicle driving
around you want to be notified if
there's something wrong with that
vehicle and the instant that we looked
at we actually asked one of our largest
customers what is the biggest single
biggest problem for you and they said
it's the electrical system that's the
biggest problem for us and
it's not the cost of a battery because
batteries are super cheap in cars but
it's the cost of the downtime whilst
that vehicle is on the side of the road
right so we looked at how can we better
predict when a battery is going to fail
in a vehicle to help this customer out
and and so we did that and after
actually there's a couple years of work
we um developed all the pipelines that
were required uh looked at all the
feature engineering we developed some
predictive models and we actually
developed predictive models uh to clean
the data uh as well too because as the
data is coming into the ecosystem
you look at something like a cranking
voltage which is one of the features we
use to figure out whether a battery is
going to fail or not and there's noise
in that data as well too so you have to
establish ml algorithms that look at bad
pranking events versus good cranking
events and so net at the end of the day
this ended up saving this one customer
millions of dollars a year and as a
result we work closely with the customer
but have now started to deploy that
across the entire ecosystem so that
we can issue these okay we think your
battery is going to fail in this vehicle
uh you should really check it out and
then what the customers can do and the
partners can do is they can take that
insight and integrate it into any other
downstream maintenance applications for
reminders and these kinds of things
predictive maintenance is going to be
common to a lot of folks listening to us
and and you know we're talking about
lots of data here i think the other
dimension is you're working with a lot
of real-time data right i think you've
got about 11 petabytes of data you're
working with real time streams going
into into your system so what are beyond
predictive maintenance what are the
other use cases you've deployed using
the google technology i mean they're so
varied and we've got a team i've got a
strong team we're about 65 on the team
right now doing
all sorts of things but one of the areas
where i'm especially proud of this year
in specific is some of the work that we
did with regards to covet
and i'll explain how
that came to play so of course and
everything hit in march and the world
kind of stopped we look to ourselves how
can we better help what can we do and we
thought you know what we're in a
position right now and we use that kind
of johns hopkins dashboard that showed
um you know how we did the countries
across the world was faring when it came
to covet cases we use that as a bit of a
litmus test for what we could do and so
we looked at commercial transportation
recovery
and we said you know what with two
million commercial vehicles across the
globe
we could be a benchmark for our
customers and for uh the public sector
to better understand and make informed
policy decisions as it relates to
recovery
not only you know within a country but
by sectors within a country so how is
the construction sector
fairing uh versus pre-code how is the
oil and gas sector faring how is a
transportation logistics really
important indicators and and so we use a
number of different google technologies
for that the data was made available
through geotab ignition which is our uh
open data aggregate data portal which is
fueled by google bigquery
and uh these aggregates this is what we
did we made it freely available for
everyone uh to to access and we created
and established connectors and one of
the most interesting ones i think was
what deloitte did with that so deloitte
connected up to that data set which we
updated on a daily basis this you know
high frequency data and pulled it into
their economic recovery dashboard and
within you know i think the first week
was about 160 000 views of the dashboard
and i think what that instilled is
the need to look at alternative data
sources
at high frequency to be able to enable
uh policy and decision making and so we
started to see a lot more interest not
looking at necessarily traditional means
for looking at things like economic
recovery so i think a really great
example and the tools that we use you
know google bigquery of course to
surface the data we're using behind the
scenes a whole lot load of other things
if you want i mean i can talk to some of
wouldn't make sense to talk to some of
that now too bruno yeah well you know i
think it would because i mean you're
using data flow as well in in the
background before we go there i mean you
have so many interesting use cases i
want to hear about the third one around
the corridor analysis which i think a
lot of people that are traveling
will be able to relate to tell us more
about about what you've done there
yeah this one's exceptionally
interesting too and uh keep in mind our
core customers are our fleet customers
but we believe that through the
aggregate use of this data there's a lot
of assistance that we can be to uh the
public sector from an infrastructure
perspective and this one came by the way
of what we did with the regional
transportation commission in las vegas
and they were looking for again this
high frequency way of looking at
corridor analysis and signal timing to
lessen congestion within the arteries in
around las vegas and traditionally how
it's done is there's a lot of physical
manual deployments of infrastructure we
said we think we can do this with just
data right so what we did is we first
devised models to figure out what an
intersection actually looks like and
that sounds like a trivial thing oh
isn't it just a point on the map mike
well no it's a little beyond that
because you have to understand the exact
geometry of an intersection as it
relates to vehicles traveling through
there to be able to provide these
metrics if we look at corridor analysis
and signal timing so we develop machine
learning models this is part of the
intersection this is oh this was a guy
that's fixing something at the
intersection a light or sitting at a
parking lot that is very close to the
intersection so now you know i find the
traffic engineer in vegas i can pull up
this application
in near real time
and have a fantastic idea of what signal
timing looks like you can choose a whole
corridor along an avenue and you get the
same diagrams at a traffic engineer
would be used to seeing but on a high
frequency basis in real time without any
deployment but the vehicles you know
moving around and again all aggregate
all privacy compliant which is another
big component of this approach so this
is precise it's real-time it's
accessible by everyone it's just these
are amazing use cases and i do want to
drill into the products as well as their
learning so as you're deploying these
products and here we're talking about
bigquery and data flow and and a host of
other technologies what what are the
things that you've learned maybe the
dues let's start with the positive news
which is which are the things that
everybody needs to go out and do when
they get started on their journey i
think one of the things if i were to
rewind five years and play things over
again
and it seems very very simple it does
it's very intuitive but i think this one
thing would go a long way for anybody
starting their drain out is just treat
data as you would any other product
right oftentimes data is a byproduct of
products and people look at it in that
fashion but if you don't treat data as a
product you end up with issues
downstream right so what do i mean by
that well i need to make sure you have
proper version control everything the
lineage i need to understand the flows
of from one data set to the next across
my entire ecosystem the notion of data
operations as well too right is is
critically important so somebody's
created the data set they leave the
company what happens to where does that
institutional knowledge go
so it's all these things that you would
think about if you were developing a
product but sometimes go by the wayside
if you're thinking about data so i think
the notion of treating data as a product
is absolutely essential i mean one of
the biggest things that we've learned
and you know if you're a data scientist
and you're not familiar with bigquery
you should be uh because it is one of
the most instrumental tools that we
leverage and use at
geotap and traditionally you know you
look at data science you're doing a lot
of scripting in python or r and that's
where you're doing a lot of your
workloads look at bigquery for doing it
we have a i think an amazing talk that's
done by one of our data scientists
daniel lewis and it's uh so it talks
about uh just do it in sql right and so
there's so much power that can be had by
just leveraging bigquery for these
massive workloads and the geospatial
analysis that comes with those tools
absolutely incredible so don't feel like
you have to do everything in python let
bigquery do more for you because it
can't and then the uh the third thing
because this is where people will get
tripped up if they go too far along a
path have a tight integration with your
privacy office because
every single data product that you
develop needs to be privacy compliant
and and that isn't easy in the lens of
data nowadays there's so many different
categories of data legislation just
changing you know every day on a
state-by-state level and to understand
uh the the implications to have a tight
alignment with data and privacy is
absolutely crucial getting these
products out the door this is amazing
and you do have an amazing team i mean i
look at the work dan's doing i was
reading this weekend the the work that
terence is doing and publishing some of
the learnings on machine learning and so
forth you really have an amazing team
that that does great work with data now
let's talk about the flip side of that
what are some of the mistakes that
people should avoid and what you've
learned that you probably wouldn't do
again if you were just getting started r
d is crucially important like it's it's
vital to creating new innovation new
product i think
we spend
a lot of time in an r d but we have to
learn how to extract ourselves from that
at some point in time and know when what
you've developed is good enough and so
often i think we think oh you know what
i'm shooting for that you know 98
accuracy on that model well guess what
the customer would be thrilled to have
something that has a 90 accuracy
depending on the product that you're
releasing and so what we found has
helped is having this notion of an
applied data scientist right so somebody
who sits between product and data who
understands the data world and can talk
the product world as well too right and
says okay r d team
we think that what you have there is
ready to take to production let's put it
into a pipeline and let's get going
right otherwise you end up burning
cycles in in too much rna and then allow
them to continue on with further
refinement for sure and then of course
i'd say you know there's there's an
easy tendency because bq bigquery is so
easy to leverage and use people just
dump things into bigquery and it creates
i wrote an article a few years back
about don't create these data swamps
right
because data lake well all good but data
swamp uh is not something that you want
and it's easy very easy oh just push it
to bq we'll figure it out later no have
a consolidated approach all comes down
again to that treating data as a product
and then the last thing
before you even touch on any modeling
whether it be analytic or
ml based make sure you truly understand
your data and the nuances in that data
how was it collected how does it change
when we're dealing with iot devices and
firmware updates what happens when
firmware is updated to the data that
you're collecting right um if you are in
predictive maintenance getting a deep
understanding for the mechanical system
behind it right or the electrical system
it's fundamental to understand you know
what happens when a vehicle is turning
over and cranking so that you understand
how you can construct your features to
further develop your model so then a lot
of times people just jump to the model
and think that the data will and there
are some amazing tools to allow you to
extract insight from from data and
that's been more democratized by google
as well too but you have to
fundamentally understand what the data
is all about before you continue to the
modeling phase well mike this has been
amazing i learned a ton and i wish i
could continue talking to you
for hours i learned about the best
practice on treating data as a product
this means think about version control
data operations lineage you know don't
think about data as a byproduct of the
work that you're doing and of course
this concept of applied data science
that i hope a lot of people here will
take and apply at their own company
again thank you so much for taking the
time to talk to us today mike and for
everybody else if you want to hear more
stories just like this make sure that
you click on the link
down below until next time i'm bruno
aziza
[Music]